so now that we've heard that our clown
prince of piracy is an emperor of the
sea we need to talk about buggy how did
this flashy character ascend to the top
of the pirate packing order how did this
fool fool everyone and gain such immense
power definitely not intentionally
probably or could it be that buggy is
actually masking his true power level
buggy did after all tank a direct hit
from mihawk's black blate there aren't
too many characters that can do that and
live to tell the tale sure his fruit is
immune to cutting but is that still the
case when we're talking about a hockey
infused strike he also took out an
awakened zone user in impul down and
threatened to challenge whitebeard
himself not only was he a regular member
of the roger pirates but was also
invited by shanks to join his new crew
after roger's death so since we don't
know yet what direction oda sensei will
be taking this in let's just assume for
a second that buggy is indeed an
extremely powerful pirate similar to
shanks who has simply been hiding his
true strength so when luffy faces buggy
in orangetown he would obviously be way
out of buggy's league and the only way
he could win this fight would be by
buggy underestimating him and being
outsmarted weirdly enough you could
argue that buggy never was really
interested in killing luffy he really
only wanted his treasure back and go for
luffy's slash shanks slash roger straw
hat that still carries the scars of when
this attack hits the reason buggy lost
this fight was because he got
outmaneuvered in his rage and given that
he not only successfully escaped impel
down keeping his true powers once again
secret there as well but survived all
types of monster attacks during the war
at marine fort it would at least fit
within the established story that buggy
is a wolf in disguise an actual yonko
i'd be absolutely on board with that but
for now let's look at the facts or at
least what oda sensei wants us to think
about buggy it seems that our clown
gained his power the same way that many
powerful people in this world do as well
through no real work or effort on their
own along with a dash of cunning and
trickery and in this case a natural
aptitude for mass media manipulation and
of course having a pretty cool devil
fruit power doesn't hurt either though
he could stand to use it a bit more
effectively for many the hierarchy of
the one piece world is merit-based luffy
and kobe for instance had to fight tooth
and nail to get where they are today
they started off as weaklings and
through insane willpower and
determination have made names for
themselves in the world however many
other characters are granted powers in
ways that have little to do with their
own will of strength characters like the
celestial dragons rule the world just
because they happen to be born as
celestial dragons and the same is true
for royalty like king riku or princess
vivi though they don't abuse their
powers in the same way of course our two
favorites recently defeated yonko big
mom and kaido ascended to emperor status
because they had unnatural inborn
strength as well judging by the
flashbacks they didn't have to train all
too hard to amass their physical prowess
big mom was just an ungodly strong child
taking down giants as a little kid
buggy however wasn't born with his power
in fact in terms of physical strength he
still really doesn't have much to speak
of it seems instead the clown star buggy
had to depend on a few
other factors like his personal
connections and the good old fashioned
power of life it should really come as
little surprise that buggy has come so
far in the story in a manner similar to
blackbeard buggy has also paralleled
luffy's journey throughout his travels
his story just like luffy's harkens back
to the east blue after all he was one of
the first major villains to appear in
the series period he was also the first
antagonist to wield a devil fruit power
with his chop chop fruit proving a
formidable challenge for the early crew
to overcome it was thanks to buggy
slashing the straw hat that nami got to
learn what it meant to luffy indirectly
leading to one of the most emotional
moments in the series when luffy gave
her the hat in arlon park and now as
luffy's bounty has grown arc by arc
buggy has scales with him becoming a
shichibu guy and now a yonko everyone
assumes that blackbeard is luffy's
greatest rival to becoming the pirate
king but does our favorite clown have a
shot as well i'm not going to lie it
would be hilarious for buggy to claim
the mantle at least temporarily so let's
explore how exactly buggy fooled
everyone and became an emperor of the
scene the first way buggy came into his
current power is that he has the kind of
networking connections that any linkedin
user would be jealous of after all they
say it's all about who you know and
buggy knows a real who's who of the
pirate world so he probably doesn't know
the character literally named who's who
buggy probably would have rotted away in
an impul down cell for the rest of his
life if it weren't for his connections
to the real hero of the story for
instance luffy being dragged along by
the absolute force of nature that is
monkey luffy he managed to escape this
supposedly inescapable prison during the
marineford war many of the escapees
rallied to his side largely because it
was revealed that he was a part of the
former pirate king's crew surely an
associate of gold d roger himself must
be a powerful leader the kind of person
you'd want to follow if you want to
hedge your bets on the future pirate
king and so buggy's ability to gain
power based on his previous associations
with pirates like luffy shanks and roger
of course are based in no part on his
own strength it seems which is lacking
to say the least however this doesn't
stop an increasing number of people from
joining him who all have power to back
them up when shanks approached the
gorosei to talk about a certain pirate
could our assumptions have been wrong in
thinking that he was talking about luffy
or blackbeard perhaps the true threat to
the state of the world is none other
than almighty bhagisma and of course we
can't underestimate the power of lying
if buggy truly does have a strength that
is it buggy is cut from the same cloth
as usual another habitual liar strangely
enough whereas you would expect a story
to impart moral lessons such as lying is
bad one piece in general has not taken a
hard stance on dishonesty whereas buggy
lies for personal gains we see usable
life for justified purposes both usop
and buggy actually inhabit a role in
literature called the trickster
archetype an archetype by the way is a
heavily reoccurring character or story
element that pops up again and again and
again throughout literature and
mythology all over the place the
trickster is a character that is cunning
deceitful sometimes malicious but at
other times heroic on the sinister side
we have figures like loki so we may meet
another trickster in elbaf on the way
more delightful side though we have bugs
bunny for instance whose name sounds
suspiciously close to buggy if you ask
me perhaps an even more apt comparison
from the looney tones cartoons though is
coyote based on the coyote characters of
native american mythologies like buggy
coyote also frequently has his own
explosive blow up in his own face i'm
actually starting to suspect that the
buggy balls must be manufactured by the
acme corporation as well now usopp uses
his lies to bring joy to others like
kaya or to ultimately work towards an
ultimate goal such as luffy becoming
pirate king however buggy uses his lies
for immoral purposes and mostly for his
own personal gain so could it be that
buggy is oda sensei showing us what an
evil usop would look like no probably
not but it's oda showing us two
different takes on the same classic
archetype buggy crafts lies in order to
bring tons of impul down escapees to his
crew long before the prisoners on
dressrosa would proclaim the glory of
god usopp buggy gained an almost
religious following after his followers
believed he was able to open a giant
gate preventing their escape and what
makes him such an effective liar well it
helps that he wholeheartedly believes
his lies thanks to his massive delusion
of grandeur we might also be able to
speculate that buggy is a little smarter
than he lets on actually his followers
listen to every word he speaks with
adoration they think he's an
all-powerful genius however it's pretty
clear to the audience that his ravings
come from his ego more so than his
intellect but could we be wrong has he
engineered more of his rise to fame than
initially meets the eye after all it
would appear that he shares the most
dangerous power in the world because
just like luffy buggy manages to amass
allies wherever he goes another reason
that buggy the clown has ascended to
yonko status is because of his grasp on
the media other than big news morgan
there are few characters in one piece
who would have a better handle on how to
manipulate public opinion through mass
meteor than buggy at the marine fight
war buggy notably took control of a
surveillance snail to broadcast flashy
messages to the world this hugely
increased his notoriety and allowed him
to become a shitty buck his narcissistic
and megalomaniacal personality couldn't
stand for monkey luffy drawing all the
attention for himself at the summit war
instead he brought himself front and
center and proclaimed himself as buggy
the
magnificent magnificent i'm actually
super curious what buggy's new yonko
bounty will turn out to be as well more
than luffy's 3 billion i would guess but
no matter how much it is it's way more
than my lousy little bounty of 61
million berries 100 for each of your
subscribers so while buggy seems out of
reach this dripping man right here with
his 99 million on his head
well that's a different story and so we
have been fighting for over a month now
to not lose the wild race to 100 million
berries against treble please help me
beat him by subscribing and getting
freshly pressed one piece content in
return every single week now true to his
status as a clown buggy is a natural
performer able to draw in an audience
it's not just his shiny red nose that
gathers so much attention in fact he'd
probably rather not bring too much
attention to that in the first place
instead of the physical strength that
allowed pirates like big mom and kaido
to take the position of yonko buggy
rolled a natural 20 on charisma and has
been making waves ever since and of
course this video wouldn't be complete
without speaking about buggy's really
cool devil fruit power so let's talk
about the chop chop fruit honestly he's
not the most effective user of his fruit
in combat but he has used it in ways
that play up the other qualities that
make him so renounced and this way he's
almost universe of luffy who used what
we initially thought to be a fairly weak
fruit and became a powerhouse on the
other hand buggy uses a fruit that is
full of potential and then usually just
ends up tied up on the ground unable to
reform himself most characters in one
piece who possess devil fruit powers
have character traits that perfectly
reflect the powers bestowed upon them by
goda blackbeard is the ultimate force of
darkness in the world galdino is a dummy
of the wax variety so how does the chop
chop fruit perfectly resemble buggy well
on the outside buggy always looks like
he has it all together
but in reality he's kind of in pieces i
mean take his post time skip appearance
where we see that he's wearing a
comically large outfit and through the
manipulation of his fruit he appears to
be gigantic in stature little do most of
his followers know that under his facade
there is no substance to this giant
figure of piracy or could it be that
just like the oversized costume he's
hiding his true powers and abilities was
he underestimated being from the east
blue supposedly the weakest c could this
brother of shanks just be lying low
until the time to make his move and find
the greatest treasure of all the one
piece after all there are few things
that buggy enjoys more than treasure
hunting and so the big looming question
that has opened up now is will buggy
fail his way upwards all the way to
becoming the pirate king or is he
actually a yonko level character in
disguise i think no matter what the
answer is it seems really clear that
hola sensei has set buggy up to play a
much much bigger role during the endgame
of one piece than any of us could have
ever imagined he might end up being the
same sort of schemer and wire puller as
shanks and speaking of shanks if you
want to understand why he stole luffy's
devil fruit from the marines you should
really check out that video right here